[Music]
it's been
unbelievable holding on to this for so
long and just seeing all these
incredible things coming to
life cut to Marvel flip
logo it's been a long time coming I
think there are a lot of fans who have
been patiently waiting to see what
Captain Marvel has been up to El de Nick
Fury prodical child of the Milky Way
after the first film we're at an
interesting spot she's dealing with
being on her own and then suddenly she's
thrust into a
situation with this new team grappling
with what it means to be a leader I know
that this situation isn't
ideal but got a
[Music]
plan I'm really excited for audiences to
see the kind of Marvel movie they
haven't seen before
it's been really cool teaming up
together we've just had the best time
that's the kind of stuff you can't plan
for is just chemistry it's just magic I
feel like I'm winning at life at the
moment Captain Marvel you took
everything for
me I think these three heroes are really
special so I'm really excited for
audiences to see these three women come
together on the big screen I'm feeling
so many feelings right
now
[Music]
Captain
Marvel we need Heroes hire further
faster baby that's
right we need you buckle up
[Music]
folks I like this one she is incredible
oh
yeah oh my God here we
go higher
further
[Music]
faster